ein auto ist in der store des
bundeskanzleramtes gefahren dort wollen
wir jetzt live hinsehen das auto ist
gegen das tor gerade es ist ein kombi
erstand aus nrw hat ein kennzeichen aus
dem kreis lippe
das auto ist beschriftet stopp der
globalisierungs politik wir sehen hier
live die bilder auto attacke vor dem
kanzleramt hier in berlin
bisher gibt es keine verletzten so viel
wir wissen das alles ist in diesen
sekunden passiert das auto beschriftet
mit stopp der globalisierung politik und
auf der anderen seite des autos soll
stehen ihr verdammten kinder und alte
menschen mörder scheint sich also um
einen versucht gezielten angriff zu
handeln wir sehen hier den notarzt wagen
vor dem kanzleramt wir sehen jedoch das
auto stehen dass dort gegen das tor das
im hintergrund zu erkennen ist gefahren
ist bisher gibt es noch nicht viele
informationen zu diesem fall wir sehen
jetzt hier gerade live die bilder vor
dem kanzleramt um 9 uhr 30 war dort
heute morgen kabinettssitzung und danach
der kabinettsausschuss gegen rassismus
um 14 uhr treffen sich heute die
kanzlerin mit den ministerpräsidenten in
einer digitalen konferenz um weiteres
vorgehen bezüglich der korona regeln zu
beraten hier im vordergrund sehen wir
stopp der globalisierungs politik sehen
wir den kombi stehen der in das tor
gerast ist und ja sehr viele polizisten
sind vor ort ein krankenwagen ist vor
ort
bisher haben wir noch nicht mehr
informationen es scheint aber alles
unter kontrolle zu sein es scheint ruhig
zu sein vor dem kanzleramt